Sometimes when you search for
something in Firebase,
you get a huge number of responses,
but that's not always ideal.
For example, sometimes you might want
to find the first 20 results, but
ignore the rest.
So for situations like this,
you want to truncate your query
results by using limit queries.
Firebase has two limit queries,
limitTofFirst and limitToLast.
Each method will limit the number
of children returned from a query.
For example, if you set a limit of
three, when you use limitToFirst,
the first three children will
be returned from the query.
LimitToLast functions similarly
with the only difference being
that it will return
the last three children.
Both methods can be used with
orderByChild or orderByValue.
OrderByChild to choose
which attribute to query.
OrderByValue to return
a limited set of results for
something like a leader board.